Sirènes
-3 attaques,
peut-être 7,
nous dit-on,
de source policière.
En tout cas,
au moins 3
ont été perpétrées
à Paris
et autour de Paris.
-On a jamais connu
un attentat comme ça
dans les rues
de Paris.
On a jamais été confrontés
à une action
de guerre.
Musique sombre
...
Coups de feu
-C'est la guerre,
l'odeur de la poudre, du sang,
la vision... C'est la guerre.
-On pense pas trop,
à ce moment-là,
on essaye surtout
de prendre
les bonnes décisions.
-Déterminer
qui a fait quoi,
comment,
avec qui
et pourquoi.
-C'est une toile,
quoi, ça...
C'est tellement énorme.
Je pars de 3 personnes
qui nous ont tiré dessus,
un an après, on me parle
d'une quantité de gens,
du financement, des armes...
Tout devient énorme.
-45 000 pièces
de procédure,
1740 parties civiles,
et 350 avocats.
Au moins 6 mois
d'audience
dans une salle
de 600 places,
construite au coeur
du palais de justice de Paris.
-C'est un procès
de très grande ampleur,
qui n'est comparable à rien.
-Ce procès,
on n'a pas le choix.
Il doit être historique.
-Que n'a-t-on pas fait ?
Que n'a-t-on pas empêché ?
Comment ça a pu
se produire ?
...
-La liberté
aura le dernier mot.
Vous avez agi de manière effroyable,
vous allez être condamné,
de manière
démocratique.
...
Musique de tension
-Bon, ça, c'est la dernière photo
de Lamia, 2 heures avant.
Voilà, 2 heures après,
elle était à la Belle équipe.
...
Donc, ça, ce sont...
C'est...
C'est en août 2015.
Donc, il lui fait...
Il y a une série de 4 photos.
Voilà, avec un poème
qu'une de ses
grandes cousines,
qu'une grande cousine,
voilà, a écrit,
parce que Lamia,
en fait, c'était...
"Lamia, coeur de Paris,
Lamia fleur de Paris",
effectivement,
c'était la plus parisienne
de mes enfants.
-Le deuil,
on connaissait déjà.
Enfin...
Dans notre vie...
Même le deuil de personnes
de notre âge.
Des deuils difficiles,
on en avait connus.
Là, la problématique...
On comprend pas
tout de suite
que la problématique
va être toute autre,
c'est les circonstances
de la mort.
Jean-Jacques, il est pas mort
d'un accident de voiture,
ni d'un infarctus.
Il a été assassiné.
-A quel moment
je me dis "l'enquête" ?
Très vite.
Personnellement.
C'est moi qui suis
plus dans...
Dans cette quête
juridique.
J'avais été
voir un avocat,
parce que je savais
qu'il y avait...
Je savais qu'il y allait
avoir un procès. Clair.
Je veux savoir
qui sont
ces bonshommes,
qui sont...
Qui ont fait intrusion
dans notre vie.
Pour moi, c'est ça.
Ils ont fait intrusion.
Il n'y a pas de souci,
je veux dire,
je n'ai pas cet aspect
"je veux rien entendre".
Non, je veux savoir
qui tu es, d'où tu viens,
pourquoi tu as fait ça,
et qui tu es !
En fait, qui tu es !
Qui tu es pour avoir tué ?
-Dès le début,
lors des attaques,
le procureur Molins
se rend sur les lieux,
il incarne la justice
aux yeux des Français.
Le procureur Molins montre
à l'ensemble de la société
que la justice est là,
qu'elle va prendre en charge
cette affaire,
qu'elle va s'en occuper.
C'est bien,
ça évite aux victimes de se dire
qu'elles vont devoir
faire ce travail.
-J'ai tout de suite
ressenti
un besoin fort,
pressant et évident
d'être au plus près
de l'évènement,
pour avoir un maximum
d'informations,
pour prendre les meilleurs
décisions possibles.
En réalité,
j'ai décidé
tout de suite de partir
de chez moi,
pour aller sur les lieux,
voir ce qui se passait.
-Avez-vous des informations
à nous donner
sur les auteurs
de ces attaques ?
Ont-ils tous
été neutralisés ?
-Vous allez
un peu trop vite.
Je vous confirme d'abord
que le parquet de Paris
s'est saisi, donc,
d'une enquête,
en crime flagrant
en matière terroriste.
On va s'attacher à déterminer
ce qui s'est passé,
le profil
de ces terroristes,
savoir le parcours,
savoir s'il y a des complices
et des co-auteurs,
dans la nature.
Vous serez, comme dans
chaque affaire de ce type,
régulièrement
informés,
pour ce qui concerne
sa compétence,
par le parquet de Paris.
Je peux rien vous dire de plus.
-Merci, monsieur.
-Il y a tout
un tas de missions
qui vont se juxtaposer,
s'additionner.
Organiser l'envoi
de techniciens
de scènes de crime
sur ces scènes de crime,
organiser l'envoi
de magistrats du parquet,
sur chaque
scène de crime.
Il faut ensuite
coordonner l'activité
des services de police,
tout en garantissant
la sécurité juridique
des opérations.
-C'est à ce moment-là
qu'on va recueillir
un certain nombre
d'indices,
notamment pour démontrer
qui a pu participer à quoi.
Retrouver, parfois,
une empreinte,
retrouver un élément
d'un téléphone portable,
qui a servi à une arme.
Un véhicule,
une plaque d'immatriculation.
Ca va avoir une importance
capitale pour la suite.
-Plus vous êtes réactif,
voire proactif,
moins vous prendrez
de retard, et mieux
vous pourrez remplir
vos offices.
Musique sombre
...
-La soirée
du 13 novembre 2015
est bien sûr gravée
dans ma mémoire,
et dans celle
de beaucoup de magistrats,
et notamment
des magistrats parisiens.
Nous passons la nuit ici,
parce que se met en place
la cellule de crise,
au parquet de Paris.
Malgré le choc,
le chaos,
tout le monde est
à son poste,
au travail.
...
-Ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé,
que je n'oublierai
jamais,
c'est le nombre de messages
de magistrats de ce tribunal,
qui me disent,
très spontanément, par SMS :
"Je me tiens à la disposition
de la justice de mon pays."
Bien évidemment,
j'ai la notion
qu'avec des attentats
ayant provoqué
la mort de 130 personnes,
j'aurais besoin
de tout le monde.
...
-Quand je suis revenu au parquet,
après mon passage au Bataclan,
je vais arriver dans une salle
qui est noire de monde.
Tout le monde est en situation,
en train de travailler.
La salle est en place,
le dispositif
est opérationnel.
...
Vous avez un chrono,
qui est tenu
par un magistrat
ou un fonctionnaire,
qui va avoir la charge
de noter, effectivement,
tous les évènements
qui se passent
et qui sont projetés
sur un écran.
Vous avez des ateliers
dont le type
ou la répartition
peut varier en fonction
des attentats.
...
-C'est-à-dire
un groupe de magistrats,
structurés,
hiérarchisés,
organisés,
qui vont se répartir
le travail,
avec chacun
des interlocuteurs spécifiques,
les uns pour
la police scientifique,
les autres pour les victimes,
les troisièmes en charge
des orientations
des investigations,
d'autres,
de l'aspect international,
avec une remontée
d'informations qui permet
de structurer l'action.
-Pour suivre,
en direct,
et pouvoir analyser
au plus près
toutes les informations,
tous les procès-verbaux,
qui remontent
des services de police saisis.
-La machine judiciaire,
au sens, effectivement,
mobilisation d'une équipe,
se met en route avant minuit,
ça, c'est clair.
Ce seront, finalement,
plus de 60 magistrats,
de tout le parquet de Paris,
qui seront mobilisés,
pour la gestion
de cette affaire.
La cellule de crise durera
une dizaine de jours.
-Pour mesurer tout
ce que ça représente,
on est à plus
d'un millier d'officiers
de police judiciaire
qui vont être affectés
à ce dossier,
y travailler
et investiguer.
C'est du jamais-vu.
-Néanmoins, cette affaire a révélé
des fragilités du dispositif.
La justice
n'était pas forcément préparée
à un si grand nombre de victimes.
Et donc, à un si grand
nombre de corps à gérer.
-Nous avons dû suivre
ce parcours du combattant,
que beaucoup de parents
comme nous ont dû parcourir.
Il y avait
ces numéros d'appel spéciaux,
mais on tombait en général
sur une musique,
ou ça sonnait
dans le vide.
Il y avait tant d'appels
qu'évidemment,
personne ne pouvait
suffire à répondre à tous.
-A la fin, j'ai quelqu'un
qui me répond, et très calme,
très rassurant,
en me disant :
"Ne vous inquiétez pas,
"le nom de Lamia
n'est pas sur les listes,
"vous ne rappelez pas."
J'attendais que ça,
qu'il me dise
de ne pas rappeler.
"Nous vous rappellerons,
si le nom émerge."
-Quand je vois
le nombre de morts,
je me demande combien
de personnes
il y a,
au Bataclan.
On me dit qu'il y a
1500 personnes.
A ce moment-là,
il y a 50 morts
donc, je me dis :
"Ca va, 1500, 50..."
Dans ma tête,
mon frère,
il a toujours eu assez
de chance, donc...
Je me dis
qu'on va le retrouver.
-Je pense que je croyais pas
à sa mort.
On entend par les infos,
qu'il y a des erreurs.
Des gens
sont annoncés morts
alors que c'est pas
les bonnes personnes.
Oui, on nous annonce
son décès,
mais tant qu'on le voit pas,
c'est pas clair.
C'est pas...
On y croit toujours un peu.
-A 8h du matin,
ils n'ont toujours
appelée, donc,
pour moi, ça va.
Au point que
sur Facebook,
parce qu'on utilise
un peu Facebook,
était déjà mis un post pour dire
"les familles endeuillées".
J'envoie, moi aussi...
Ca, j'oublierai jamais.
J'envoie aussi mon mot
de solidarité avec toutes
les familles endeuillées.
Musique oppressante
...
-J'ai ouvert une enquête
en flagrance des chefs
d'assassinat
en bande organisée,
en relation avec
une entreprise terroriste,
pour association
de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminelle
de nature à commettre
des crimes
d'atteinte
aux personnes.
On peut dire
que très vraisemblablement,
ce sont 3 équipes
de terroristes coordonnées
qui sont à l'origine
de cette barbarie.
...
-Alors, en fait,
ce qui va se passer
le soir du 13 novembre,
il y a 2 kamikazes
qui vont mourir
au Stade de France.
Ils vont se faire sauter
autour des différentes portes
du Stade de France.
...
Une personne décède,
de nombreux blessés.
C'est pas qu'un attentat raté.
...
Ensuite, 3 terroristes
vont mourir au Bataclan.
...
Enfin, il y a le commando
qui a attaqué les terrasses.
Brahim Abdeslam est le frère
de Salah Abdeslam.
...
Brahim Abdeslam va se faire sauter
au comptoir Voltaire,
et ensuite,
trois personnes prennent la fuite :
Abdelhamid Abaaoud et Chakib Akrouh
et, séparément, Salah Abdeslam.
-Tout le monde est
dans les starting-blocks
pour, à la fois,
conduire les investigations
et mener la traque des fugitifs.
-Nous avons été amenés,
au niveau du parquet de Paris,
à saisir dès la nuit dernière
le parquet fédéral belge,
le parquet fédéral
antiterroriste belge,
de quatre demandes
d'entraide pénale internationale,
et en particulier une demande
d'entraide pénale a visé
ce véhicule Polo,
retrouvé devant le Bataclan.
Musique pesante
...
-François Molins me contacte
en disant :
"Nous avons des plaques
d'immatriculation belges.
"Ils ont trouvé la voiture
"près du Bataclan,
c'est du belge,
"donc je vais te contacter,
il va y avoir des infos.
"Mets le maximum là-dessus."
Dès la nuit, on est mobilisés.
...
-Isabelle Panou,
je suis juge d'instruction
au tribunal de première instance
de Bruxelles.
Je suis magistrat spécialisé
en matière de terrorisme.
Dès le lendemain,
dès le 14,
j'ai été saisie
par le procureur fédéral
en vue d'instruire à charge de X
pour des faits de participation
à des activités terroristes
et assassinats terroristes.
Très rapidement,
les liens entre la Belgique
et les attentats de Paris
vont ressortir,
et dès lors, la désignation
d'un juge d'instruction s'impose.
-Donc, dès ce moment-là
commence une phase
où on est en mode chasse à l'homme.
Musique pesante
...
-Salah Abdeslam, donc,
est un ami d'enfance
d'Abdelhamid Abaaoud.
Leur maison était mitoyenne
et Abaaoud ne vivait pas là,
mais il y avait le commerce
de son père.
-Les frères Abdeslam,
ils sont connus
pour des faits de stupéfiants
et ils ont un mode de vie
qui se situe
aux antipodes du Coran
tel qu'interprété
par l'organisation
de l'Etat islamique, et donc,
ils ne sont pas dans le radar
qui nous occupe à ce moment-là,
le radar du terrorisme.
-Salah Abdeslam va servir
un peu de taxi
aux différents terroristes.
Il va aller chercher
un peu partout en Europe
les futurs commandos
du 13 novembre.
-Le soir du 13,
Salah Abdeslam,
après avoir déposé
le commando du Stade de France,
il remonte
vers le 18e arrondissement de Paris
où il laisse sa voiture,
ainsi que ses armes.
Il ne conserve
que sa ceinture explosive.
Musique sombre
...
Ce qu'on sait, c'est qu'à 22h30,
il va acheter
une puce de téléphone qu'il active
et il rentre en contact rapidement
avec deux amis à lui,
en Belgique,
des dealers de shit,
des délinquants de droit commun,
pas du tout des grands chefs
de l'Etat islamique.
Ensuite va s'en suivre
un périple que je trouve étonnant.
Il va faire une boucle
qui contourne Paris,
qui suit le périph par l'ouest
pour aller au sud,
à Châtillon,
où il va se retrouver dans une cité,
allée Vauban,
dans les Hauts-de-Seine.
Musique sombre
...
Il y a une chose qui m'interroge,
et j'aimerais bien comprendre :
on parle d'un Belge
qui est venu rarement à Paris,
à part dans les jours précédents
pour louer les appartements.
La Belgique, l'autoroute A1,
c'est Porte de la Chapelle.
Il laisse sa voiture
à une centaine de mètres
de Porte de la Chapelle.
Il appelle deux amis qui doivent
venir le chercher de Bruxelles,
et qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Il traverse tout Paris
pour se retrouver plein sud.
Alors moi, ça m'interroge.
Ca a beaucoup interrogé
les services aussi,
qui ont beaucoup pensé
qu'il pouvait espérer
avoir un relais dans ce coin.
Une fois à Châtillon,
il s'est caché dans les parties
communes d'un immeuble,
il rencontre deux adolescents
avec qui il discute.
Son comportement
ne montre pas particulièrement
que c'est quelqu'un
qui a participé à un attentat.
On sait aussi qu'il s'est débarrassé
de sa ceinture d'explosifs
à quelques centaines de mètres
derrière cet immeuble.
A 4h du matin, les adolescents
quittent Salah Abdeslam
et on sait maintenant
qu'à 5h30 du matin,
ses deux amis belges sont présents
et le remontent vers la Belgique.
Musique sombre
...
-Je rappelle,
l'état d'urgence est décrété
par le président de la République
dans la nuit.
Il annonce l'état d'urgence,
mais il annonce aussi
un renforcement important
du contrôle aux frontières
et des dispositifs
sont mis en place.
A 9h10, les gendarmes,
au niveau de Cambrai,
décident d'arrêter
ce véhicule suspect.
Ils sentent quelque chose
qui n'est pas très clair.
On est quelque heure
après les attentats du 13,
et voilà, ils trouvent
que c'est pas naturel.
Les gendarmes font traîner
un petit peu les choses,
prennent en photo
les cartes d'identité,
font un contrôle un peu plus poussé
qu'à l'ordinaire.
A un moment donné,
on leur dit de relâcher
la voiture.
La voiture repart.
Quelques dizaines
de minutes plus tard,
coup de téléphone
à ces gendarmes en disant :
"Interpellez Salah Abdeslam,
que vous venez de contrôler."
Evidemment,
les gendarmes avaient relâché
Salah Abdeslam
et il était impossible
de le retrouver.
-Oui, il y a un petit raté
le lendemain...
Un gros raté, même,
le lendemain
de l'attentat du Bataclan,
lorsqu'il est arrêté
par nos propres forces de sécurité
sur l'autoroute A1
et qu'on procède à la vérification
de son identité,
à l'interrogation
des policiers belges,
qui nous indiquent
qu'il ne représente pas de danger,
qu'on peut le laisser partir.
-Salah Abdeslam est signalé.
Les services de police français
qui l'interceptent
voient qu'il est signalé,
posent la question,
mais le laissent partir
avant d'avoir la réponse.
-Ce qui est extraordinaire,
c'est que dans la boîte à gants
de la voiture qu'on retrouve
devant le Bataclan,
vous avez tous les papiers
de location de la voiture.
Si on avait ouvert
la boîte à gants,
on aurait trouvé des papiers
de location de véhicule
au nom de Salah Abdeslam.
Ils les ont retrouvés le lendemain,
après les contrôles.
Le lendemain, il est déjà revenu
à Schaerbeek, enfin à Bruxelles,
et donc, voilà,
il est passé entre les mailles.
-Que ce soit la faute des Français,
que ce soit la faute des Belges,
que ce soit la faute
de qui vous voulez,
ça ne change rien.
Je dois retrouver des auteurs
et je dois les interpeller
afin qu'ils répondent de leurs actes
devant les juridictions françaises.
-On va pouvoir remonter la piste,
entre autres à travers
les contrôles de véhicules
et des caméras de vidéosurveillance
des stations-service.
Musique pesante
...
-Il arrive en Belgique,
et la première chose qu'il fait :
il cherche un coiffeur.
Abdeslam ne se contente pas
de changer de coupe de cheveux,
il va sur un marché,
il achète des vêtements
et il change de look,
exactement comme s'il devait
changer de look avant,
pendant et après son attentat.
On retrouve là toujours les mêmes
préceptes de la cellule des OPEX.
C'est vraiment des réflexes
d'agents secrets.
-Et ensuite,
il va souhaiter entrer en relation
avec un autre ami,
aussi mis en cause.
Cet ami, ensuite, le perd de vue,
le dépose en voiture,
et on perd à ce moment-là
complètement Salah Abdeslam.
Musique pesante
...
-C'est une grande ville,
Bruxelles :
1,250 million d'habitants.
Salah Abdeslam est un bruxellois.
C'est quelqu'un
qui a toujours vécu à Bruxelles,
qui connaît bien Bruxelles,
c'est quelqu'un qui bénéficie
d'un réseau social d'amis,
et très rapidement,
il y a des interpellations.
-Recule, recule !
Recule !
Pas bouger !
-Premiers inculpés :
Mohamed Amri
et Hamza Attou.
Interpellés durant le week-end
qui suit les attentats,
ils auraient véhiculé,
entre Paris et Bruxelles,
le suspect toujours en fuite
Salah Abdeslam.
Ali Oulkadi,
lui aussi a transporté
Salah Abdeslam,
de Laeken à Schaerbeek.
-Les deux amis de Salah Abdeslam
qui vont venir le chercher
et celui qui l'aide sur Bruxelles
sont arrêtés.
Salah Abdeslam
leur a encore échappé.
Musique intrigante
...
-Cette autre hypothèse
qui surgit ce soir :
celle d'un deuxième homme en fuite,
un deuxième,
un autre membre du commando
qui a fait feu
sur les terrasses des restaurants.
-Là, les services français
recherchent deux personnes :
l'homme aux baskets orange,
qu'on a vu
sur des vidéos des terrasses,
dans des vidéos de la RATP.
On parle beaucoup moins
de Chakib Akrouh, qui était là.
Les services ont sans doute voulu
préserver cette information.
-En effet,
Abdelhamid Abaaoud est vu à 22h14
à la station de métro
Croix de Chavaux,
en compagnie d'un second individu,
non identifié.
-Donc, on sait maintenant
que Chakib Akrouh
et Abdelhamid Abaaoud
ont trouvé refuge
dans des buissons à Aubervilliers,
si je me trompe pas,
dans une zone un peu
industrielle et cachée.
Il contacte assez rapidement
des gens en Belgique.
Il va donner les coordonnées
de sa cousine,
qui habite
à côté de Saint-Denis,
qui va venir chercher Abaaoud
avec une de ses amies.
L'amie de cette cousine
va appeler les services de police,
qui vont pouvoir vérifier
que le renseignement est vrai,
se rendre compte que Chakib Akrouh
et Abdelhamid Abaaoud sont présents.
-On pense qu'il est en Syrie.
Nous ne savons pas qu'il est
sur le territoire national.
Oui, bien sûr,
c'est un choc,
et puis,
je vois les quelques images
qui ont été prises par les services
à ce moment-là.
-La question,
c'est pourquoi
on ne les voit pas arriver ?
Est-ce que c'est normal ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on rate Abaaoud ?
Je pense que ce sont des questions
sur lesquelles les juges
vont devoir s'arrêter.
Ce sont des questions
qu'on va poser.
Musique sombre
...
-Il y a cette impression
de se dire
qu'il y avait
toutes les pièces du puzzle.
Les services avaient une idée
assez précise des commandos
qui s'apprêtaient à frapper
et de ce que l'Etat islamique
était en train de préparer.
Ils ne se sont pas fait duper,
mais malheureusement,
sur certains moments,
ils arrivent trop tard,
et ce "trop tard" fait 130 morts,
ou plus.
...
-Ce que l'on découvre,
c'est qu'Abaaoud, finalement,
n'a pas de base arrière,
c'est qu'il est perdu,
qu'il ne sait plus où aller
et qu'il se réfugie
là où il le peut.
-Et nous devons conduire
une opération
de mise hors d'état de nuire
de cet individu,
qui peut frapper encore.
Il est surveillé,
suivi, lorsqu'il part à Saint-Denis
en sortant de son buisson.
je me souviens très bien
de cette nuit
où je suis tout seul
dans la bibliothèque de Beauvau.
Le directeur général
de la sécurité intérieure,
Patrick Calvar,
me tient informé par téléphone
quasiment en direct
de ce que ses collaborateurs voient,
dans les voitures
qui suivent le véhicule d'Abaaoud.
...
Donc, je suis ça vraiment
minute par minute.
-Nous avons logé,
si je puis dire, Abaaoud.
Nous savons exactement où il est
et où il allait se cacher,
dans ce squat à Saint-Denis.
C'est jamais facile
de faire une opération
comme celle qui a été menée
pour neutraliser Abaaoud,
en pleine ville.
Donc, nous avons,
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur,
fait en sorte
que l'opération soit...
...la plus efficace possible,
c'est-à-dire neutraliser Abaaoud
sans qu'il y ait
la moindre conséquence
pour le voisinage.
*Coups de feu
*...
*-Ba ba ba...
-L'assaut est donc terminé
à Saint-Denis.
-Il était probablement le cerveau.
Le Belge Abdelhamid Abaaoud
a été tué hier matin
pendant l'assaut
des forces de police.
-Abdelhamid Abaaoud, qui a rejoint
cet appartement de Saint-Denis,
préparait un projet d'attentat
imminent,
puisqu'il aurait pu avoir lieu
mercredi ou jeudi,
et qui devait se passer
à la Défense.
-J'ai la frustration,
je l'ai parce qu'Abaaoud a été tué
dans les...
A Saint-Denis et n'a pas été
arrêté dans les...
-Forest.
C'est Abaaoud dont j'ai besoin.
Il doit m'apporter des réponses.
Depuis janvier 2015,
il est dans les...
Dans les... Dans le...
Comment on dit ça ?
Collimateur.
Donc on sait.
C'est le personnage
que j'aurais voulu...
Parce que je pense
que pour nous, oui...
Regarder dans les yeux, voilà.
Pour certains d'entre nous,
un procès, c'est ça.
-Le 18 novembre, c'est la deuxième
fois que je rallumais la télé.
C'était le matin,
je devais aller travailler.
Je suis pas allée travailler.
Je suis restée sidérée deux
ou trois heures devant ma télé.
Je me suis dit : "Est-ce que c'est
la fin de l'enquête ?
"Est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres ?
"Qui ils étaient ?"
-Le matin du 18 novembre 2015,
alors que l'assaut du RAID
est en cours,
celui qui a fourni l'appartement
aux terroristes
clame son innocence
devant notre caméra.
-On m'a demandé de rendre service,
j'ai rendu service.
On m'a demandé d'héberger
deux personnes, je l'ai fait.
Je ne sais pas
d'où ils viennent.
Si je savais,
je les aurais pas hébergés.
-Et votre nom et prénom ?
-Bendaoud, Jawad.
-Daoud, Jawad, très bien.
-A partir du moment où il va falloir
se prononcer sur le sort
de cet individu,
pour une éventuelle mise en examen,
le parquet a l'obligation d'ouvrir
une information judiciaire.
Le président du tribunal
intervient
pour la désignation
des juges d'instruction.
-Devant l'immensité de la tâche,
il voit grand.
Il décide effectivement
de désigner six juges d'instruction
qui vont s'organiser
et se partager la tâche.
Musique pesante
-Le parquet nous le dit,
on va arriver
avec presque une vingtaine
de tomes constitués.
Il faut savoir qu'en gros, 20 tomes,
c'est la moyenne des tomes
d'un dossier fini
à l'antiterrorisme.
Là, en commençant,
on va avoir 20 tomes.
-Je me souviens
de leur avoir dit :
"La France vous regarde."
...
-Le travail d'un juge d'instruction
antiterroriste consiste
à enquêter sur les faits
dont il est saisi,
et dire,
à la fin de son enquête,
s'il y a suffisamment d'éléments
pour que les personnes
à qui les faits ont été imputés
soient ou non jugées.
-Jamais six juges d'instruction
n'avaient été désignés
sur un même dossier.
C'est, à ma connaissance,
une première dans l'histoire.
-Christophe Tessier est
décisionnaire,
mais on se réparti le travail
de manière thématique,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a un
qui va se charger
des expertises génétiques,
qui sont très nombreuses,
un second de toutes les expertises
balistiques,
d'autres des victimes.
On se répartit le dossier
thématiquement
dans un premier temps,
pour faire face à l'urgence.
...
-On se trouvait nous
devant un hiatus
qu'on avait peu connu.
Les faits sont commis en France
mais on s'aperçoit
assez rapidement
que très peu de choses préparatoires
ont été commises en France,
et que c'est une enquête qui,
obligatoirement, passera
par une coopération internationale,
d'abord avec la Belgique,
et notamment un moyen qui a été créé
relativement récemment,
qui s'appelle
l'équipe commune d'enquête.
-L'équipe commune d'enquête permet,
je le dis toujours,
aux policiers français de devenir
des policiers belges
et inversement.
-Quand un collègue français
travaille avec moi
dans une procédure en Belgique,
les actes que nous posons ensemble
ont directement valeur
d'actes de procédure en France,
avec pour conséquence
un gain de temps
et un gain d'efficacité
tout à fait considérable.
Musique étouffante
...
-Lorsque nous commençons l'enquête,
nous n'avons personne
en face de nous.
Quand vous n'avez personne,
il faut pallier à cette absence
de personne.
On le pallie
par les examens techniques.
-Quels sont ces éléments ?
Le premier est une image vidéo
au Stade de France,
qui montre, à 21h01,
l'un des terroristes kamikazes
du Stade de France
un téléphone à la main.
Deuxième élément,
c'est un téléphone
qu'on va trouver dans la poubelle
devant le Bataclan, qui est
le téléphone d'un des terroristes,
et ces investigations téléphoniques
vont permettre de démontrer que l'un
des 15 000 appels du Stade de France
et le boîtier de la poubelle
du Bataclan ont activé
la même cellule téléphonique
en Belgique.
-On tire un fil.
On part par exemple
d'un texto
qui part du Bataclan
qui dit "On y va".
Ils partent de ça, des GPS,
et aussi de la téléphonie,
de l'achat des cartes SIM.
-Parfois, vous avez des personnes
en contact avec un numéro
et on se rend qu'ils sont en contact
à des moments problématiques.
Ces numéros ont été en contact
avec d'autres numéros,
et encore d'autres.
Ca a permis d'avoir
une énorme toile,
qui nous a permis
de pouvoir localiser les personnes.
-Des milliers
de policiers mobilisés
en Belgique mais aussi en France.
-D'ailleurs, ce matin,
une vaste opération de police
a eu lieu dans ce quartier.
Des unités d'élite
armées lourdement, cagoulées,
équipées de gilet pare-balle.
-Ce week-end, des perquisitions,
sept personnes interpellées.
Deux ont été écrouées.
-Nous décidons d'intervenir
sur toutes les pistes
que nous avions pour éviter
qu'il se passe quelque chose
vis-à-vis des informations
des services de renseignement.
-On a lancé une offensive
sur le terrain,
et dans les premiers jours,
on a fait 120 perquisitions.
-Un 6e suspect a été placé
sous mandat d'arrêt, hier.
Il s'agirait de Mohamed Bakkali.
Pas de confirmation du parquet
sur son identité
mais l'inculpé serait en lien
avec la maison perquisitionnée
cette semaine à Auvelais.
-Mohamed Bakkali,
on m'en a parlé
lors de l'attentat du Thalys.
C'est lui qui aurait convoyé
le terroriste du Thalys
et Abdelhamid Abaaoud
quand ils sont revenus en Europe
depuis la route des migrants.
Il participe
à la préparation des attentats.
Il va louer des appartements,
des voitures,
il va faire des trajets.
-Les véhicules loués
sont équipés de GPS,
donc c'est autant
de renseignements utilisés
dans le cadre de nos enquêtes.
Musique énigmatique
...
-En remontant la piste
de Bakkali,
des choses qu'il a pu louer
et de ce qu'il a pu faire,
on va commencer à retrouver
les différentes caches à Bruxelles.
...
Il y en a qui ont servi
à la préparation des explosifs,
d'autres de lieux de vie,
il y en a qui ont été abandonnées
parce qu'elles étaient "cramées"
où ils se doutaient
qu'il y avait des problèmes.
Ils se déplaçaient.
...
Un site de préparation des explosifs
est à Schaerbeek,
qui était l'endroit principal
où étaient fabriqués
les explosifs qui vont servir
pour le 13 novembre
et pour le 22 mars,
également loué par Bakkali.
...
-De l'instant
où Abdeslam retourne à Bruxelles
jusqu'au mois de mars,
l'équipe sur place
fabrique de l'explosif
en quantité très importante.
C'est du TATP,
l'explosif qu'on retrouve
dans les ceintures explosives
qui ont été utilisées
au Bataclan.
On parle de centaines de kilos.
Le maître d'oeuvre est
Najim Laachraoui,
qui a été formé par un artificier
de l'Etat islamique
et qui était le patron
des geôliers des otages à un moment.
-Lors des perquisitions, on trouve
des éléments qui sont analysés.
Certaines caches étaient vides
mais nous ont permis d'avoir
des éléments intéressants.
D'autres ont été abandonnées
précipitamment,
laissant beaucoup
d'éléments intéressants
qui permettent de rebondir
et encore rebondir.
-Quand les policiers
perquisitionnent
en remontant la piste
via Mohamed Bakkali,
ils découvrent des ADN des membres
des commandos du 13,
et aussi d'autres ADN.
...
La première pensée des équipes
à ce moment,
c'est : "Il reste
"des membres de commando qui ne sont
pas morts pendant les attentats
"et qui étaient présents
avec les commandos du 13-Novembre
"à préparer une opération
conspirative.
"Où sont-ils ? Que font-ils ?"
Musique pesante
...
-On a peur qu'il se passe
quelque chose,
on sait que ce sont
des éléments incontrôlables,
ce sont des gens qui sont poussés
par une idéologie
qui leur a fait tuer
130 personnes à Paris.
-Pourquoi voulez-vous
qu'ils s'arrêtent ?
Les attentats de Paris
se sont produits,
une partie des membres
de la cellule
ont été tués ou interpellés,
mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre suspect.
-Les enquêteurs se rendent compte
que les terroristes se sont fait
de fausses cartes d'identité.
-Grâce à ces fausses identités,
on a pu faire un travail policier,
identifier les lieux
qu'ils ont loués
avec ces identités.
-Les enquêteurs suivent le fil
et découvrent la maison à Forest.
...
-On est entraîné, on s'y prépare,
mais la réalité est toujours
différente.
C'est une confrontation et un choc.
...
-Le 15 mars 2016,
on a affaire
à une localisation froide.
Différents éléments
tout à fait concrets
attestent du fait
que cet appartement conspiratif
ne doit plus être occupé.
-Les enquêteurs vont demander
au rez-de-chaussée,
aux voisins
s'il y a encore quelqu'un.
Pour les voisins, c'est pas clair.
Ils voient parfois quelqu'un,
mais les gens sont gentils.
Ils ne font pas de bruit.
Ils montent à l'étage,
Ils toquent à la porte,
il n'y a personne,
apparemment,
qui vient ouvrir.
Ils défoncent la porte,
les enquêteurs.
-Là, ils tombent sur Salah Abdeslam,
accompagné de Sofien Ayari
et de Mohamed Belkaïd.
Mohamed Belkaïd est présent en Syrie
depuis très longtemps,
c'est quelqu'un qui est très aguerri
et un gros poisson
de l'Etat islamique.
-Il y en a un des trois
qui ouvre directement le feu
et qui tire sur les collègues
français et belges.
...
Un collègue est touché,
son arme est touchée
et son holster
de ceinture est touché.
Le collègue a eu beaucoup de chance.
Ils sont acculés.
Ils arrivent à partir,
à s'évacuer.
La force de réaction rapide
stationnée dans la caserne
est avisée et part
dans les minutes qui suivent
après la demande radio
pour se diriger
vers la rue du Dries, à Forest.
Musique grave
...
-Il y a une espèce
de Fort Chabrol
qui se créé,
où c'est surtout Belkaïd qui tire,
pendant qu'Ayari, Sofien,
et Salah Abdeslam
s'échappent par l'arrière.
Musique lourde
...
-La force de réaction rentre
dans l'immeuble,
et un
des trois,
qui est Belkaïd,
se trouve encore
dans l'appartement.
Quand le premier,
le chef d'équipe,
passe sa tête
pour faire une fouille,
c'est là qu'il tire,
et il tire une rafale, en fait,
de kalachnikov.
Une des balles
touche le collègue.
Là, on a un blessé,
qui tombe. Dans l'assaut,
il est évacué, il est retiré
de la maison. Là, on se rend compte
qu'on est tombé
sur un gars qui...
Lui, il n'a pas pris la fuite
et il est là. Il est décidé,
il va pas se laisser faire.
...
Ca dure encore deux heures,
deux heures et demie.
Il y a des centaines de coups de feu
qui sont donnés
parce que le gars ne se rend pas.
Finalement,
il apparaît une ou deux fois
devant la fenêtre
en front de rue.
Il y a un de nos tireurs d'élite
qui a une fenêtre pour l'abattre
et il l'abat dans cette fenêtre.
Musique pesante
...
Sur place,
ils retrouvent des breloques,
qui sont bien à Daech,
c'est-à-dire des drapeaux noirs,
à l'effigie de Daech,
des munitions.
On retrouve des...
des chargeurs de kalachnikovs.
C'est clair que c'est une planque
pour Salah, qu'il y a été.
Ils retrouvent de l'ADN.
-Il était là, mais on est...
très court derrière lui.
Donc, on exerce
une réelle pression,
on est très proches.
Il nous sent.
Il sent qu'on est derrière
et d'ailleurs, ça va déterminer
la suite des investigations.
-Ca remet l'église
au milieu du village, en disant :
"Les gars sont bien ici.
"Il y a encore une ou deux cellules.
Ils sont préparés."
Musique pesante
...
-Salah Abdeslam va être victime,
si j'ose dire,
du professionnalisme
de cette cellule terroriste,
c'est-à-dire que les terroristes,
pour préserver l'intégrité
de la cellule terroriste,
si l'un d'eux tombe, en fait,
il en sait le moins possible.
En quittant sa planque-refuge,
Abdeslam ignore tout
de la planque-refuge
de l'autre partie du groupe.
Et donc,
il se retrouve livré à lui-même.
Il n'a pas
d'autre planque où aller,
et donc,
il va appeler un de ses amis,
que les policiers belges
ont déjà mis sur écoute
au lendemain du 13 novembre.
Ca va permettre de remonter
jusqu'à Salah Abdeslam
et de l'interpeller.
...
-Les enquêteurs font leur boulot,
ils jettent leurs filets
bien loin pour aller...
aller pêcher
ce qu'il y a à pêcher.
Finalement, il est logé
rue des Quatre-Vents,
à Molenbeek-Saint-Jean,
parce qu'il voit
qu'il n'y a plus d'activité
dans les autres endroits
où il pouvait se trouver.
...
-La presse belge,
ou certains organes
de presse belges,
sont au courant
et on leur demande de se taire.
L'info ne sort, finalement,
que le vendredi,
par un journal français,
alors que nous avions prévu
d'intervenir de façon sécurisée,
au milieu de la nuit, etc.,
là, nous sommes obligés
d'intervenir
dans un quartier
à grosse majorité musulmane,
à la sortie de la prière,
à la sortie des écoles.
C'était un vrai cauchemar.
Ca aurait pu très mal tourner.
Propos en néerlandais
...
-Dans ce genre de dossier,
il y a tellement de personnes
qui sont au courant
qu'il y avait souvent des fuites,
et donc,
quand on est arrivés sur place,
y avait deux équipes de télévision
qui étaient...
dont une qui était
quasi devant sa porte.
-Ja, ja.
Brouhaha
-Recule !
Allez, recule !
-Ja.
-Dégage !
-Ja. We worden hier opdet
omgeblek weggestuurd.
-Mon équipe, donc,
on est passés par l'arrière.
On est passés
par la cour de l'école, puis,
par les toits.
On a traversé la cour de récréation,
et là, deux de nos grimpeurs,
qui sont avec moi dans l'équipe,
voient un bonhomme sortir,
avec une casquette, habillé en noir.
Ils crient "police", mes collègues.
Et là, il regarde vers le haut,
il se rend compte
qu'il est encerclé
et il repart dans l'autre sens.
Musique de tension
...
Donc, le collègue voit
une ombre,
qui sort dans le couloir,
qui est tournée.
Il a mis sa capuche
et il est tourné dos vers la porte.
Et il recule. Mon collègue donne...
fait les sommations,
donne les injonctions,
veut qu'il se retourne,
qu'il lève les bras.
Là, il se retourne,
il est quasi nez à nez
avec le collègue,
mais ils sont pas vraiment
en légitime défense,
et là, il sort
et il sort en courant.
Tir
Cinq tirs sont déclenchés.
Musique de tension
...
-Salah Abdeslam, il est pas rentré
dans la salle du Bataclan.
C'est pas une des personnes
qui est rentrée
dans la salle du Bataclan
et qui nous a tiré dessus.
Pour moi,
ces personnes-là sont mortes.
Donc, j'ai du mal,
au début, à...
à bien... à bien
me rendre compte de l'importance
du fait que Salah Abdeslam
soit arrêté.
-C'était une bonne surprise,
notamment
qu'il se fasse arrêter vivant.
Donc, on s'est retrouvés, vraiment,
avec un des auteurs principaux,
clairement identifié,
arrêté et qui sera présent
dans le box des accusés.
Donc, tout de suite,
ça donnait un procès qui était déjà
hors norme
par le nombre de lieux touchés,
le style de l'attaque,
le nombre de pages du dossier.
Ca lui donnait
une consistance humaine.
-Le dernier membre du commando
du 13 novembre est arrêté, vivant,
et c'est le seul vivant
des membres du 13 qui est arrêté,
donc c'est une victoire
pour les services belges.
Ils arrêtent en plus un membre
qui faisait partie du commando,
qui n'était pas présent à Paris
et ils espèrent pouvoir
retrouver, surtout très rapidement,
les autres membres
qui correspondent aux ADN retrouvés
dans les différents sites belges.
Musique pesante
...
-De toute façon,
on savait que la fin de la traque
de Salah Abdeslam, ça marquait pas
la fin de la cellule.
Le risque était, effectivement,
que ces personnes, qui sentaient
que l'étau se resserrait
autour d'elles,
ne commettent un acte,
pour finir en beauté,
parce que pour eux,
finir en beauté,
c'est faire le plus de victimes
dans la population civile.
-Quand on retourne quelques jours
avant dans la rue du Dries
y a un enquêteur que je connais,
qui discute avec moi.
Lui, il me parle
des frères Bakraoui.
Les frères Bakraoui,
nous, on a travaillé dessus
pour des faits de grand banditisme.
Il me dit, innocemment :
"Les Bakraoui,
"on ne sait pas où ils sont
et ça me fait un peu peur."
-Le 13 novembre n'était pas
la fin de l'opération.
L'arrestation d'Abdeslam
n'est pas la fin.
C'est un groupe qui va muter,
jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus personne.
-Les deux coordinateurs survivants
de la cellule terroriste
que sont Najim Laachraoui
et un des frères El Bakraoui,
échangent avec le chef
de la cellule des OPEX,
qui est, lui, à Raqqa.
-Ils expliquent
que c'est fini pour eux,
donc il faut se dépêcher.
Y a pas d'autre solution
que de passer à l'acte.
Musique pesante
-"La situation est telle
"qu'on ne peut plus retarder
quoi que ce soit, tu vois ?
"On doit travailler au plus vite.
On a décidé de travailler,
"Inch'Allah, demain,
mardi 22 mars, en matinée,
"parce qu'on n'a plus de planque
de sécurité, plus personne.
"Il n'y a plus de frères
pour la logistique.
"Tout le monde est cramé.
Tu vois ?
...
"En matinée,
il y a des vols américains,
"des vols russes,
"des vols israéliens.
On va essayer de les toucher.
"Les cibles,
ce sera l'aéroport et les lignes
"de métro, tu vois ? Direct."
Et ça se termine là-dessus.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...